i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground
in a world of conflict and division all
too many believe that if you're not with
us you must be against us
but does every problem have to be solved
by the loudest voices or the biggest
armies
tonight day by day evidence of torture
rape and murder emerges from ukraine
russia stands accused of war crimes
president zelinski's people are hanging
on literally for grim death
but the kremlin's special operation
launched they say as a swift strike to
rescue russians from rule by a nest of
nazis is not going well
putin's response is not to retreat but
to turn up the heat
britain's leaders are today urging no
peace without a russian climb down they
want world leaders to impose more
sanctions on moscow and send more arms
to cave
but the ukrainian president called for
talks and an end to the carnage and some
say it's not our place to sacrifice
ukrainian lives for our principles
our choice
should we in the west do more to help
ukraine fight on against putin or are we
simply fanning the flames of war
in the next 60 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the journalist and
broadcaster peter hitchens and dr jade
mcglinn author and academic at the
monterey initiative in russian studies
let's start with you peter um
should we help ukraine to continue
fighting for uh russian withdrawal
through sanctions and more weapons
i think
that's really i have to answer that with
the question
that
that uh the the man got in ireland when
he asked
where he should go next and the man told
you i wouldn't start from there if i
were you this whole thing goes back so
much further than that
that it's not a question i want to
impale myself on what i do want to say
absolutely from the beginning because
this is important for this debate even
to survive
is that i utterly condemn
as barbaric
lawless
stupid and unforgivable the invasion of
ukraine by vladimir putin
unequivocally and without qualification
and that in any part of this discussion
anybody who assumes or presumes that i
think anything else is making a major
mistake i understand you want to get
your retaliation in first i have to get
it in first because we're we're actually
in circumstances i get that when i get
ready free debate i get that it's
extremely difficult at the moment and
not if
now we're going to start from the
premise that everybody's here
uh on basis of goodwill nobody here is
an apologist for putin or for cruelty or
anything of that kind what we're really
trying to understand
is
whether
the west and in particular our country
should continue
to ramp up the sanctions and
uh offer the ukrainians
more weapons and you may say
it would be better if we weren't in this
position but we are
and i just want to get clear
where you
we'll talk about how we got here in a
moment but
right now somebody has to make a
decision and if you're advising them
what would you be advising them well
here's a simple point both united states
and britain have for some time before
this invasion took place and before
anybody could honestly say they knew it
was going to be taking place have been
supplying ukraine with very large
numbers of weapons
that hasn't changed uh except that the
the supply has undoubtedly increased and
not merely weapons but also military
advice and training at a very high level
and presumably uh
the the terms
on which those could be supplied easily
so that was already the case before the
invasion the second point that i make
from my actual position on all wars is
this i i i am a christian believer
i believe in just war which is
it's almost almost never is it possible
to justify war it's never possible to
justify aggressive war all war should be
defensive and limited as far as it
possibly can be
and as far as i'm concerned the quicker
that the war is brought to an end
uh then the sooner the horrible
suffering which has already been
inflicted on so many innocent people
will come to an end too i'm shocked by
the almost total absence of any
international effort so get this water
well and i wanted i wanted to end i have
to say we'll see if the answer to your
question is if you see a fire do you
okay do you pour water on it or petrol
all right i say water what do you say
we'll go uh into that in detail jay let
me ask you the same question
um
peter essentially says
we are we've been
pouring fuel
and that actually we should stop
and find some water
so i think that um the only person or
the only people who started this war are
putin and his advisers of course sadly
with the support of quite a few russian
people
of course there's a discussion to be had
about historical you know
what's happened about the historical
background that's led us here and i hope
that we have time to get into that today
um
but
i think that if the ukrainians are
asking us for weapons then we should
provide them and one of the main reasons
for doing so
is not only of course that we should
take into account the agency of
ukrainians which is something that
vladimir putin is not doing but also
because
as we've seen from the images just this
that have come to the fore just this
weekend from butcher and the on bronze
of kiev
just because the battles stop doesn't
mean that the killing will stop living
under russian occupation will not
will not person end to the killing
um i think
that
the aim needs to be for ukraine to
i'm not sure that it's a winnable war
since since i think i don't think it's
winnable for anybody especially in the
sense that obviously i think and i
hopefully i and i presume that i share
this with peter i think that was peter's
point that our main emphasis here and
our main concern should of course be
minimizing the number of deaths of
ukrainian of ukrainians
but i simply don't think that that's
going to happen by giving into russia i
think that there will be more deaths
that way all right before we get into
the meet a bit i want to just ask each
of you
to tell me why this
thing matters to you personally both of
you have spent some time living
uh in russia or soviet union um
you referred to just wars sin augustine
and all of that
is that your motivation here why you
think this matters so much
well i i am motivated by that and it's a
very important part of my thinking but
obviously also uh i i'm influenced by
the fact that i spent some very
important years of my life in that
country
i arrived in russia as more or less
russo
uh i i was also a
hugely anti-communist cold warrior not
not something i didn't regret in the
slightest but i had developed the the
strong russophobe feelings here was a
country where they had lots of snow
bears a funny alphabet
and they were unfriendly and cold and
horrible and i discovered very rapidly
this is complete nonsense and the ceased
to be a russophobe quite quickly and in
the time that i spent there i gained
something extremely precious i was i
lived in a country which doesn't exist
anymore where no one can ever go i lived
among russians in extraordinary
circumstances and i witnessed events
that nobody else will ever see and i
have this strong view as a journalist
from from those to whom much has been
given much is required and when i see
huge misconceptions abroad
among my colleagues and rivals and in
politics and in in the national
discussion generally i have a duty
to speak out and say this is mistaken
you have this wrong okay jade
why why is it uh an issue for you
unlike peter i've always been a rustle
file i fell in love with russia when i
was 13 and i taught myself the language
from a book i then went on to study it
obviously to do free degrees in it but
in between that time in 2011 i moved to
russia and i intended to spend the rest
of my life there really yes i did um and
it was only the events in 20 that
happened in 2014
the shooting down of donbass but it was
particularly
i was originally a literature scholar
not not of politics i only went into
politics for my phd
and
i found it so
devastating how people who i knew to be
intelligent people were
choosing to mouth falsehoods about for
example passenger mh17 that was shot
down in july 2014 about how it would
have been preloaded with corpses
and actually it was all just a big
effort by the west to malign russia and
i wanted to understand how on earth a
society gets to that point where its
relationship with the truth and with
reality is so broken
um and i think we're seeing
unfortunately that actually what i've
hoped might be an extremity a point of
extremism in that relationship with the
truth in 2014 was only the beginning of
a very very dark journey and i would say
that the biggest russo vote out there
must be vladimir putin because he's
completely destroying his country's
reputation he is giving
so much fuel to people who are genuine
russophobes and he's put his own
country's security at risk as we can see
because obviously he sits amid a vast
mountain of corruption with that i
completely agree well this is very
interesting that we we start from our
premise that we have two people who
basically love this country uh russia
and by the way i love this one too
yes let's let's not get into that both
love
russia itself and by the way you know
anna karenina greatest novel ever
written except for
charles dickens let's start with you
peter
um
we can come to the history in a moment
but i just want to ask you about some
things happened today
jens stoltenberg the secretary general
of nato said actually
the next two weeks
would be the right time to put the
russians on the back foot militarily
because they are if not in retreat
they're regrouping and so on and now is
the time
really
to step up the pressure
um
is your timing just wrong
i don't know i mean i i don't claim to
be any sort of military expert i have no
idea it would seem to me that you have a
difficult position
uh for any kind of offensive uh if the
if one country has a very large army and
it's established on the territory of the
country that's invaded and the other
country has quite a small army and not
much in the way of defensive capacity
quite what it can do in
in the next two weeks to put the
russians on the back foot in that sense
it also seems to me the russians are
already on the back foot in that
whatever their original whatever putin's
original plan may have been i think we
can fairly uh
fairly readily assume that it has he's
failed to meet it they simply were not
equipped uh technically uh or in terms
of discipline or training to deal with
particularly with the lightweight
anti-tank weapons which have been used
to smash so many russian tanks they
simply haven't coped with it the whole
the whole invasion if it was an invasion
has been beheaded uh and they there are
there are areas where they've made some
military progress but in general i think
that they're already on the back so why
not simply uh prosecute
the conflict in a way that gets them
out of that's right i'm out of ukraine
as quickly i'm not a military expert but
as i understand it taking ground which
is held
by heavily armed and equipped soldiers
is a fantastic difficult thing to do
uh
holding ground is much easier and once
they once they've got it it's very hard
to get them out of it and i don't think
from what i know of ukraine's armed
forces that they have much of an
offensive capacity so i don't i don't
see how that would work but
i'm happy i'll happily concede that
point to any expert who can tell me that
i've got it wrong but if i were asked to
say uh is that a realistic prospect it
doesn't look to me
unless we've been completely misled
about the nature of ukraine's armed
forces and their size and capacity that
that's really much of a possibility
unless other armies come in which i very
much hope they weren't do you um
accept that
look and to be clear nobody here
certainly i don't think that you are a
patent apologist or anything like that
but would you accept that
the case for
not ramping up the pressure
could play into the kremlin's hands in
which they might be saying well look
even clever people in the west are
saying that they should the ukrainians
should
just give up and sue for peace now well
in this in circumstances like these
anything i say can be portrayed as
playing into putin's hands uh
but that that would be to assume an
attention an intention which i don't
have
uh and you can't play into putin sounds
unless that's what you intend to do one
of the things that always amuses me is
when i'm accused of being a useful idiot
something which a term which lenin is
supposed to be used i am a former then
about about the most part the last thing
you can accuse me of as a former
awareness is political naivety uh but if
you're going to have a free discussion
in this country i mean frankly i do not
think that vladimir putin is sitting in
his vast ballroom of an office waiting
to hear what i say about the war before
deciding what to do i also doubt that um
however though i'm sure what you have to
say is very will be interesting um
so
of course
i mean if you just you only have to
watch social media to see that they will
jump on absolutely anything that is said
um by people that could be construed as
pro-putin or pro-russia however they
will just create it if it isn't said so
i don't think there's any point really
in getting caught up in that
what i would say is that i think the
more important thing here is to not see
now that russia on the back foot what i
don't want what i am wary of is any
attempts to then force ukraine or to try
to push or pressure ukraine into a
ceasefire because i think that although
it sounds nice of course who doesn't
want the who doesn't want the fire to
cease
um in actual fact russians as we've seen
multiple times in syria will use that as
a chance to regroup
and then it will um they will interpret
that as um as western weakness and i
think it's difficult i think the issue
of sanctions for example that you
mentioned as well is an interesting one
because sanctions aren't we can see
nobody of any importance has resigned
from putin's sort of inner circle as it
were so if we say take the most 40 sort
of most high-ranking officials um and
and politicians
and they probably won't and i don't
think that the sanctions having lived
there in 2014 when sanctions were also
imposed um quite quite strong or it felt
comparatively strong at the time now
obviously seems less so there was a
rally around the flag effect i mean it's
not that people welcome the sanctions
but
it won't have the effect that it will
bring people out onto the streets what
it will do i think is show putin that
the west isn't this decadent country
that isn't this decadent space um and i
use that i know it's an imperfect term
but collective west um
that won't stand up for its values that
has given up on itself and that really
will just sell out um
but actually is willing to
make sacrifices and hurt itself but at
the moment i'm not quite sure that the
west has made those sacrifices it has
made those sacrifices convincingly
enough isn't that a
fair point peter that actually
uh
by
essentially trying to keep the keep up
the pressure whether it's by sending
arms whether it is by ramping up
sanctions or whatever that actually what
we're doing is sending a clear message
to the kremlin that
their thought that they can push us
around essentially is wrong
it's a perfectly fair point
i just don't think it's particularly
relevant when what's actually happened
there's been a a russian invasion which
has failed
and it plainly failed and and and the
the it has been it's been decapitated uh
it's more or less halted in the in the
center of the country around kiev uh
it's now bogged down in various
conflicts in the east which were areas
which the russians
largely controlled in the first place
and that's it and putin
putin has a problem with that anyway is
that it i don't i i but ukraine
i mean let me just just interrupt you
for a second question but this one i'll
let you introduce just a challenge one
point
it's it's not just that's it ukrainians
are still dying
and being tortured that was it and they
were murdered
immediately
one tries to deploy reasons then someone
brings in emotion uh i um have you you
must have been in war zones you must
have seen i have what a human head looks
like after a bullet has masturbated yeah
i don't like it it's a disgusting war is
absolutely disgusting event that nobody
could possibly wish either to start or
to continue any longer and in war i have
to tell you both sides generally behave
disgustingly it's not just one side and
to get and
and to make out that it is there has
been a war in ukraine since 2014
and it's perfectly well documented i've
written about it you've done this read
about it and in it i'm afraid both sides
have killed civilians they do but only
they've done this this is the other only
only one country invaded another
sovereignty that's true and and
we've established that and this this is
wrong and it has to be put an end to so
how do you put an end to it practically
practically and and
and effectively and swiftly how do you
put an end to it the problem with the
first world war which is which is in
some ways
all this pallava reminds me of
is that the
the level of of public war hysteria was
raised so high
on both sides that even though by the
middle of 1915 most of the of the major
participants realized they made a
terrible mistake they couldn't get out
of it
because the war had become such a public
issue uh that they had to carry on
fighting even though there was nothing
to be gained if you think this is war
hysteria sorry
and then i would suggest um well i would
presume that you don't have a telegram
account in russian because that is
really war history just before we go to
break peter let me ask you one one thing
which is really
um i think that surprises me about you
we've just been talking and jade makes
point that uh the kremlin thinks of us
as weak and decadent and it seems to me
the case you're making it's perfectly
rational
but it feels a bit like the sort of
liberal western self flagellation that
you know we are responsible
and so on that you rail against week
after week in your columns and that
frankly would lead the russians to be to
thinking that they're right about how
weak and decadent we are well i don't
know i mean we we may be weak and
decadent but certainly in terms of the
the military power of the united states
there's no question that is neither weak
we're not using it that is not neither
weak nor executive we certainly are
using you know the
united states since the 1990s when
ukraine first became independent uh has
spent huge quantities of money on on
paying for ukraine to develop military
strength and enormous all right and and
we we have to get on to some point the
issue of nato expansion all right uh
which which is which is a vital part of
this and indeed we are going to talk
about that a little later but we're
going to take a break now um
we're going to test the ground with
jade's view
after this break
[Music]
yeah i tried to do this basic i couldn't
work for the basic people e5 on the late
shift papa knows i can't afford to waste
gifts not to justify the waiting
reinvent yourself amazing you don't have
to decide to make all in your mind is
undiscovered greatness
sometimes hesitate to get involved we
actually started this company to
champion black stories and black talent
but also just tell diver a story so
we're very very happy that these films
are showing this week
i grew up in an environment that i feel
like had certain expectations of black
ways the way that you had to carry
yourself the way that you had to
communicate the way that you had to
dress and i think a lot of it was
survival mechanisms that lent into toxic
masculinity however when i left this
area and i went to university and i
started working in the arts i felt that
i had to do the opposite i almost had to
code switch to make people that i was
around feel comfortable and almost
dispel the stereotype of black boys and
black men that was in media and so like
after that i almost felt like i didn't
fit into either of these worlds and none
of them were a true representation of
who i was and so i wanted to make a film
about that impulse of wearing you need
to that impulse of space where you need
to decide who you want to be as a man
and so that's essentially what butterfly
effect is about
yeah i mean music videos
were and have been an amazing i guess
stomping ground to be able to cut my
teeth in terms of direction and working
with talent and it's been amazing i
think like we've been able to create
like a few moments that have lived on in
the
in the world of music videos and
hopefully they'll be joined by some
narrative work i'm going to do going
forward as well
[Music]
[Music]
organized
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined once again by the journalist and
broadcaster peter hitchens and dr jade
mcglynn author and academic at the
monterey initiative in russian studies
we're talking about whether the west
should be doing more to help ukraine
fight on against russia um jade
let's um
talk about your thoughts that actually
we should really be put putting the
pressure
on the russians um
what do you really expect the end game
to to be here you know this could be
heroic but the charge of light brigade
was
heroic so in terms of the end game i
i can't pretend that i exactly know i
don't think anybody can and if if they
say they do i wouldn't trust them
unfortunately i think what it looks like
we're going to have is a very long nasty
and drawn out war
and the main reason for that is of
course because the russians invaded but
it's also because because the ukrainians
i think have surprised everybody this
i'm not a military expert but they
certainly surprised me um with
both their capabilities but also with
their their real commitment um to
fighting but ultimately for vladimir
putin this is um
he also perceives this to be an
existential fight the ukrainians quite
rightly perceive this to be an
existential fight it is it's a fight for
their very right to exist that is what
denotification means in putin's language
it means
de-ukrainianization
they've been very explicit about that
just today and yesterday in state media
and with politicians such as dimitri
medvedev
however for russia putin he is also
seeing this as quite as an existential
question but more in terms of
his ability
to show russia as a great power his
ability and perhaps slightly as well his
ability to stay in power because of
any sign of weakness could presumably be
pounced on by elites but this is putin
as a tribal chieftain he's going he
wants to bring the slavs together and
all of that and he's been pretty clear
about it but in terms of our stance um
you know we're thousands of miles away
from the action and it's okay for us to
say
they should fight on but actually
they're they're dying no of course and i
think um we shouldn't be the ones say i
i really disagree with the idea of of
course fighting to the last ukrainian
that's a horrific idea i have many many
friends in ukraine and that would not be
something i'd be advocating however
that's not what's happening ukrainians
are asking us for arms because they want
to defend themselves and it's their
right if they want to do that i
personally think we should support them
because i think that they're dying for
values that we in the west are supposed
to espouse whether or not we always live
up to those values that's a different
discussion we certainly don't live up to
them as much as ukrainians are right now
but i think we should support them in
that fight because eventually do we
think that
the
the ma the killing that what we're
seeing is essentially a genocide of
ukrainians this these awful sort of
murders of
civilians you know these rapes of
children do we think that they'll just
stop in ukraine or do you think they'll
come further because fine for us in
britain we may be some way away but
poland isn't the baltic states aren't
there's lots of threatening comments um
coming out um from russian politicians
now towards those and then that does
start to affect us because of course
they're nato countries and
then that's our broader discussion i
think we'll come to you later but um
that's i don't think it's a case of
fighting to the last ukrainian i think
it's a case of they want
support they want they're asking to help
defend themselves and we should the
least we can do is help them to defend
themselves peter um
we've been
mining the biblical references uh it
feels a little bit like uh jade is
saying we can't walk by on the other
side
well we haven't walked by on the other
side uh the question is what the best
way of not walking by on the other side
is i don't remember the good samaritan
providing a submachine gun or an
anti-tank weapon to the good samaritan
at any stage that wasn't his job uh the
the the question remains how did we get
here uh what is this why are we in this
as i say the whole the whole
question goes unexamined
i was in moscow the day that ukraine
left and became independent
i remember boris yeltsin uh complaining
that the the new independent ukraine by
containing
large numbers of russians was going to
have great difficulties and he also made
this issue about kazakhstan and i think
other parts of the former soviet union
and being immediately rebuffed by the
then president kravchuk and told to shut
up i think probably also told to shut up
by the americans
and looking back on it one has to wonder
whether it wouldn't have been better if
ukraine hadn't come to some agreement
about this long long ago i'm amazed at
the feebleness of efforts to obtain
peace
the
collapse through almost total lack of
interest of the minsk agreement uh and
the and the the normandy variation on it
which which was supposed to avoid uh uh
avoid war and and to end the 2014 war
the remember
vladimir zelinsk zielinski was
elected on a program of obtaining peace
he tried very hard to do so
and very bravely went to confront uh
some of his own soldiers who resisted it
um
his predecessor poroshenko campaigned
against his attempt to gain peace uh i
think zelensky deserves enormous credit
for the efforts that he made i do not
think there's much sign if you look at
the diplomacy of the period between 2014
and now
of the western countries particularly
the united states making any serious
effort to avoid this war i won't go
further and i will also refer you to a
very important point i i haven't yet had
anything like as much time as jade just
said
i think
and it goes like this last friday in the
daily telegraph fraser nelson quoted a
senior different matter saying that the
a view in
in the west was that they wanted a long
war in which russia could effectively be
bled white
okay so um
peter
peter's point jade is that actually
uh we're essentially fighting a proxy
war at the ukrainian's expense
i doesn't
so the first one is about the number of
ukrainians um there are sorry the number
of russians in ukraine but there are
loads of ukrainians in varronese in
branson
why doesn't ukraine then have the right
to go that's just there's an answer to
this very important the nature of
ukrainian nationalism it's not like
scottish nationalism it's not civic
nationalism it's very ethnic and the
arguments over language for instance
have made quite a lot of russians
particularly in crimea and in under the
east as you'll know because you've been
there very uncomfortable with what's
going on if the language if the language
law of ukraine was imposed for instance
on the on the french speakers of quebec
they'd explode all right
absolutely
let jade make her point are you
referring to language law of 2014 or
you're referring to the amendments made
in 2022. referring to
okay um so
this is just a narrative that is
completely out of control of course
there are some nasty nationalists in
ukraine but the idea that ukraine isn't
a country fueled by civic nationalism
what are we seeing what are we seeing
right now ukraine is a country that has
an incredibly robust civil society which
is one of the reasons why its resilience
in this war has been so incredible
we clearly cannot say the same of russia
russia is a country that is only unified
around a war that it won 80 years ago
and that it's not allowed to properly
remember or properly mourn anyway and
where the 27 million dead are just used
to help putin and his other sort of
kleptocratic mates get richer and stay
in power so i don't think
there's any
i'm really surprised that you would sort
of dismiss the idea of civic nationalism
in ukraine most ukrainians speak russian
i can't speak
i study ukrainian and i can't speak
there's nobody who would speak ukrainian
to me can i just can i just respond i
don't just miss
that well why should it be brief it's an
important one
because i want you to you did you look
let me just remind you peter says make a
point all right let me let me remind you
what you said what you said was you have
to understand the nature of ukrainian
nationalism yes and it is not civil
nationalism about scottish nationalism
not scottish national party it is
ethnic that's that's what you say much
more ethnic and the the the the worship
of figures very controversial things
like stephen
figures such as stephen mandera is is
very shocking to large numbers of of
russian-speaking ukrainians and always
has been there and there's the the
naming of
football's stadiums after roman
chukevich is also pretty shocking too
you look up okay people they're not it's
not it's it doesn't it's it's it's like
it's like erecting statues of of of
jerry adams in warrington to some people
it just isn't a very sensible right
thing to do
the language issue is not minor all
right if you want okay to get into
ukrainian civil service the chances are
you have to speak ukrainian you've made
the point um before we go to the break i
just want to quickly ask you a question
jade um you said earlier on of course
correctly that we're providing defensive
weapons
is there a danger that what we're
actually really doing is saying
uh that we're providing weapons a lot of
support
to allow the ukrainians to lose slowly
rather than to win we're not giving them
up
films by which they can mount a
counter-offensive so
is there any point well maybe we should
give them weapons demand to counter
offensive if that's what they need
clearly we need to start thinking now
about the medium term clearly the
russian army has been gutted by the
corruption
that rips through every single aspect of
russian society very sadly um so perhaps
we should start thinking about that i do
just want to come back on one point
because i think it's
very very briefly on um the worship of
stephen now i agree i think seven
mandarin
was obviously um a terrible person i
have no time for it and there are the a
ukrainian nationalist leader yeah who
whose followers collaborated with the
nazis and
however
apart from in a very small area of the
west the support or
the sport fame is very low recent
polling shows that people see him as one
of the most divisive figures in
ukrainian history
all right
because we've got to go to a break now
uh we've heard what both of our guests
think about each other's cases to an
extent but i um
want to take some control here and see
if we can find some common ground in a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving forces to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back i'm joined once again by
the journalist and broadcaster peter
hitchens and dr jade mcglinn author and
academic at the monterey initiative in
russian studies we're talking about
whether the west should be doing more to
help ukraine fight on against russia we
found out some of what our guest thinks
and think and why um and now
my challenge can we find if not some
common ground at least some common
understanding and let's start maybe with
a um a negative
one
um
how much of this situation has been
created as the russians would say
by nato's decision to expand to the east
in the 90s
well i think an an enormous amount and
huge numbers of people have
warned against it uh including henry
kissinger this is the the one issue in
which henry kissinger and noam chomsky
united
uh from the very start the senior
diplomats jack matlock
president reagan's
invoice of moscow who dealt with the
with mikhail gorbachev was against it
jaegor gaidar the prominent liberal
russian politician actually went to his
friend the canadian ambassador in moscow
and begged him to try and prevent nato
expansion it's just been over and over
and over again uh the the
all the intelligent diplomats have said
don't do this it will create in in
russia which if you remember when this
began was entirely different from the
way it is now it will create in russia
uh a defensive nationalism which is
extremely dangerous and it insults the
people in russia who had in
1990 what
had actually achieved a russian
democracy for the first time since lenin
smashed it up in 1917. so that's
it's hugely important and anybody who
ignores it is making a great mistake and
the other thing which is totally ignored
and was barely reported in any western
media was the nature of the of the
violent mob push which overthrew the
legitimate government of ukraine in
february 2014 2014 yeah when
young kovich i think it was yes um
jade what do you think uh
how big a part does history have to play
here okay that's that's a huge question
i wrote an 80 000 word thesis on that
so i won't go into that in too much
detail but um i think history has a
great role um in terms of how putin uses
it to legitimize um his crimes in
ukraine but i just want to come back to
the nato point now clearly an
opportunity was missed to
um
create um a more inclusive european
security framework um in the 1990s i
think that i would find that very hard
to argue against
um i think that the west made lots and
lots of mistakes with russia including
sort of um supporting um yeltsin even
after the shelling of the white house
including sort of their um helps for him
to sort of rig the elections and
including their support for shock
therapy um which has given rise to a
narrative of humiliation by the west the
economic shock economic shock therapy
exactly prices up let the markets
let the market flow in yeah exactly used
to be able to afford a house today you
can afford a car the next day you can
afford a fridge the next day you can
afford a sandwich um this sort of rapid
um impoverishment of the russian people
and the 90s was definitely a terrible
time and i think that nato also made a
mistake with the bucharest memorandum
because they led ukraine on they clearly
ukraine was never going to be able to
join nato
however and this is a big however
a lot of the nato expansion narrative
and even that phrase is slightly
problematic because you have to ask well
why did everybody want to join i mean
nato didn't force nato didn't force the
baltic states to join the obvious or
poland destroying obviously wanted to
join for a reason i think perhaps now
we're looking at maybe some of the
reasons why they might have been
frightened for their security but even
with that this is very much a narrative
for external consumption for the west
this isn't really a narrative that comes
up in russian justifications that are
actually in russian language for their
own people that's right
doesn't say this to russians
not really i mean he does mention it's
not that it doesn't exist but it's very
much for externality in 2007 at the
munich conference putin specifically
raised it as an
issue responsibility at the music
security conference
sorry wait a minute the response in 2008
at the bucharest nato summit was that
george w bush proposed that ukraine
should join nato if you can't really
imagine a bigger a a bigger two fingers
that anybody could have offered uh
having been
uh uh after the afternoon i've already
said that i think that the bucharest
memorandum is stupid but i think this is
not talked about the russians are guided
to guide us no but the problem is here
that you're applying just you're trying
to apply essentially a sort of realist
western paradigm to understand russia
and what it's doing in ukraine when it's
based on emotions it's based on
imperialism understandings and history
of ukraine you defer to george cannon as
somebody who knows more about russia and
the soviet union than either others you
better explain everybody knows what
george kennan said around nato expansion
i've already said that i think it was a
mistake that there wasn't a more
inclusive european security framework
constructed after the fall of the
society much more specific than that
george cannon was the inventor of the
cold war he was the man he was the man
not everybody watching this will know
this george kennedy was the man who
devised the policy of containment which
eventually defeated him indeed
98 he said something which i really
think i people need to know he said of
nato expansion which had been rammed
through the senate by bill clinton and
also by by very heavy lobbying by arms
contractors he said i think it is the
beginning of a new cold war i think the
russians will gradually react quite
adversely and it will affect their
policies i think it is a tragic mistake
there was no reason for this whatsoever
no one was threatening anybody else this
expansion will make the founding fathers
of this country
peter honestly honestly your point is
made very clearly without the supporting
uh statement yes
good support to have yeah
okay okay russia but the point the point
here if i can bring it back to ground is
that actually
um the question the question was really
uh as you said that uh the west's
decision to bring in
some of the old soviet possessions as it
were uh the baltic states and so on into
nato was uh seen as a provocation jade
is making the point that that might be
what they say but it wasn't a motivation
for this particular no it wasn't this
particular action
let's
you are not going to agree you're not
going to die
how about paul wolfe yeah you're not
going to agree about that let me let you
know
you're not going to you two are not
going to agree about that let me try
something let me try something different
here um one of the things that will be
uppermost in viewers minds right now is
a humanitarian situation
is there any
point in which at which
that takes precedence
over
if you like the um
state the actions of states because what
we've been talking about now at the
moment is what governments do and what
governments don't do and so on but is
there a point at which actually things
become so extreme mario paul
perhaps uh some some
uh of the suburbs of uh kiev and what
we've seen on tv that actually all of
that has to be put to one side and there
has to be some kind of intervention
well when you say intervention
intervention by what i mean is boots on
the ground no fly zone anything to
protect i thought you might i thought
you meant that body called the united
nations which seems to have been struck
down yeah absolutely useless yeah well i
think okay we can all immediately uh
already agree that the united nations
has not been very useful in this country
but let's but let but let's where's
anybody been
trying to trying to secure peace
well almost total absence as as with the
mints as with the minsk agreement there
it was a possibility for peace nobody
the major sponsors of it didn't have
nothing to do with this agreement was
very difficult because essentially
ukraine and russia had two very
different ideas about what the minsk
agreement meant and you i appreciate why
you want to sort of bring the us into
this but really germany but germany and
france
can i stick to the question i've asked
you both is there a humanitarian
uh cause is there a moment when the
deaths and the cruelty meted out to
people
uh
supersede if i like if you like the
strategies and the interests of states
well of course and i think we've long
since reached that point but
unfortunately putin they have a lot of
nuclear weapons so we need to be
realistic about what a no-fly zone means
and it would mean only more dead
ukrainians through the use of a tactical
nuclear weapon probably on ukrainians
it would it would draw it would draw the
whole of europe and possibly the united
states into a general war
and would be an act of of
something near insanity and if you if
you're talking about the sort of uh
idealistic intervention that was made in
iraq in 2003 i think the civilian death
toll from that was was pushing towards
200 000 dead dead people and huge
numbers of others maimed rendered
homeless and forced into in
into becoming refugees these
interventions posed in libya there was a
humanitarian intervention by libya
remember that turned the place into a
cauldron of screams and it still is is
in total chaos thanks to our
humanitarian supposed intervention be
very careful about being seduced by that
particular agreement on libya but
obviously we're discussing ukraine okay
so uh we've got one piece of common
ground which is
don't be tempted by the humanitarian
impulse all right i'm going to ask both
of you in a moment to tell me if in this
discussion
um
you've heard anything that's changed
your mind about your own view uh
you obviously i think i can say pretty
clearly has not have not been persuaded
by each other but i'm going to ask you
just give me a minute each uh on that
but what i think we have both
agreed is
uh there are no putin apologists here
everybody's appalled by what's going on
uh everybody wants this to stop as
quickly as possible uh nobody thinks in
this room thinks that we should be
putting uh boots on the ground or
imposing a no-fly zone um what i'm not
quite hearing is how we get out of this
hole so
jade what have you learned
so i found it very interesting
conversation i am no in no way saying
that peter is a patent apologist but i
do find interesting because obviously
some of the points he raises are also
quite common points in russian media
so it's been quite interesting to debate
those but with somebody who's putting
them forward logically rather than
simply
in the services
of putin
and i think it's important that they are
debated i think that um it's important
to understand and to contextualize i
just happen to think that peter is
focusing on the wrong points of context
that he's bringing them too much to the
fore and trying to make general rules
out of things that are really small
issues or not as important as others and
loses sight of the bigger picture which
is that russia has invaded ukraine it is
pursuing a policy of genocide to destroy
the existence of ukraine and we have
seen pictures of charred children's
corpses of raped children and we really
need to bear that in mind when we get
into these discussions we need to bear
that human cost in mind when we get into
these discussions over sort of what
happened when in 1943
peter is there anything that you've
heard from jade that has made you think
uh
maybe i should moderate or modify
my position or my understanding both of
the past and what we might do now i
think we have a lot in common and i i
wish that people in the british
government would get hold of jade they
certainly won't talk to me would get
hold of jade and ask her because she
actually knows something about the
subject about which most of our our
government totally lamentably ignorant
uh they
they know nothing about the history or
nature of the problem at all so i would
very much hope they would they would
listen to her because she has a lot of
sensible things to say i would point out
as always uh that we're all
uh horrified uh by the the butchery and
murder of war and
that unites all human beings
no one should use that
in a rational argument to gain any kind
of
of advantage or suggest that they care
more than anybody else uh we all care i
trust
equally do we not
but let me just actually quickly ask
each of you just 30 seconds
what should be the next step what would
you do tomorrow
i would start training ukrainians to
help them encounter offensive weapons
because nato very soon is going to run
out of its supply of soviet era weaponry
and we need to start thinking about the
medium term because unfortunately this
is going to be a protracted war and i
don't think putin's going to give up on
his obsessive desire to possess ukraine
good i think it's time the general
secretary of the united nations put
together a serious plan
uh for bringing an end to the war as
soon as possible before it spreads and
becomes a general conflict lasting for
years
well here's what uh what i think i think
that
it's going to be very difficult to find
common ground between the two of you
because actually you
attribute what's happening today
to
very different causes peter
understandably
we haven't had time to go into the depth
of history i think that you'd like but i
think we've got some sense of uh
where you think the west has failed to
create the uh conditions to avoid where
we're going here
this is such a great opportunity and to
some extent
when i was in moscow that day when in in
in 1991 when the whole thing collapsed i
was so completely filled with hope and
it's now all been squandered and to see
this is just so tragic it's uh i think
again yes and i i get and i get your
point but your point is essentially that
because we've allowed that opportunity
to go uh missing uh that
go begging a big pardon uh we haven't
really now got much in the way of
weapons to solve the problem uh your
your point i think jade is that whatever
that background is uh we
have to do everything that we can do at
least to try to minimize the suffering
the thing that strikes me in some senses
about both of you and i don't mean this
in any sort of terribly negative way
it's it's to be honest rather a gloomy
piece of common ground
is that at some level both of you think
that whatever the outcome whatever path
we take the ukrainians are basically
bound to suffer for quite some time to
come and there is almost nothing that
anybody can do about it and maybe uh if
there's common ground here it might be
that um our government needs to tell
everybody
don't look for the cavalry to come over
the hill to solve this one i think there
are things we can do and one of the
things we can do is calm down the the
war hysteria and the idea that this is
gandalf versus the orcs it isn't it's
much more complicated than that okay and
we should there is also in this in this
society since 1945 we have had a
mechanism for the prevention and ending
of war that we're not using and which we
should use in which every civilized
government should be putting pressure uh
on the united nations and the and the
competence to observe it's time this
ended we don't want any more corpses we
don't want any more refugees in theory
of course but in reality we can see that
there is absolutely no preparation
towards making peace in russia the
person who's the head of the
peace delegation is um
a completely
over-the-top patriot nationalist who
thinks that russians have a special gene
because of their heroism in history and
he is now being called a fifth column a
traitor to the russian people because he
even suggested even slightly moving um
in that direction that didn't happen
without somebody say some a nod an
editorial nod in the kremlin there's no
there's no position they're not moving
towards peace they're not preparing for
problems
okay so it's very striking here that
we're really saying that the passions
that are being played out there
are not going to be controlled but i am
very grateful to both of you
for dealing with such a difficult and
passionate subject in a civilized and
rational way quite rare that's all from
us this week next week we'll be joined
by two more passionate advocates in the
search for common ground
[Music]
you